so what's the future man are we all
gonna be back to living in
huts and caves and um that's what
happened when atlantis got smashed
twelve thousand eight hundred years ago
historically uh what a comet
shattered okay okay okay i don't want to
talk about landings
let's talk about what happened yes let's
let's keep it okay good idea political
appeal what happened to what happened to
the people
so look so so i mean italy still exists
right i mean it's probably still like
like rome as a city still
exists right the roman it got a nile in
terms of the people
it got conquered and then re-conquered
and then conquered back and then
reconquered right
right yes people were living in like
shelled out buildings and and the
population was decimated by 90 plus
and so and so when you put all this
together right when you do put all this
together
when you talk about the the weakening
of the us as a system right the us as a
system
and then you go to the military side and
you can see
so russia iran and china are telling us
what we need to do in
our backyard and then you've got um the
u.s navy study that comes out that says
look we would lose a major conflict
right now on the seas we would lose
it just straight i say there's a former
naval officer and i think they're right
like we we are not ready to fight
a near pure competitor right um you know
if imagine the u.s losing and i'll just
put it out there imagine the u.s losing
a maritime conflict over taiwan
like china moves on taiwan we say we're
going to defend them we say no
we japan comes to you know rallies um
but korea says you know
not worth it maybe and then uh australia
says you know we'll we'll pitch in
um but really you know the us is leading
the whole thing and they just straight
up lose
if that happens what think about what
that does to american
to the american psyche not just the
american decisive decision
what happens when right when
when the united states has blood in the
water and all the sharks start coming
realizing the us can't defend its allies
anymore
all it takes when you look at what
happens in a lot of these countries like
the police break down in south africa
where the cops are actually looting now
once the unrest gets to a certain point
people say
the cops can't stop us and we saw in the
united states in baltimore and ferguson
the police can stop you know it's like
whack-a-mole when the whack-a-mole is
coming up really slow the cops can go
and stop
unrest but when they keep coming up like
crazy there's not enough when i was in
so i was in the freddie gray riots
um not participating um but um
the thing that got me about that was the
speed right the speed at which the whole
city just i was driving down the street
and i saw
some random people walking the street
just stop and throw something through a
wait no
i'm in the rob from the store and what
blew my mind was that
you knew it was gonna happen if everyone
in the city knew
there's gonna be riots tonight it'll
probably be around 5 5
30 and the police were basically told so
the governor hadn't called in uh the
national guard yet actually a buddy who
was called up in that
but for the first night there was no
national guard right
um you have the mayor stephanie
rawlings-blake who says we need to give
them
room to protest right uh marilyn mosby
gives this the her no justice no peace
uh speech blocks me on twitter yelling
about her
um completely illegal but i'm actually
glad that uh that she blocked the okay
boomer girl uh blocked me today actually
congratulations oh thank you
i just said thank god thank god just uh
uh
wasn't she doing like a promo for a
phone or something so she was doing a
promo for a phone
yeah and then someone said to her like
oh are you gonna do an ios version and
then she responds
team android right and then on the tweet
because it says like how what you know
what format
it said tweet by iphone on the tweet
so i just quote tweeted that and i wrote
a tweet by iphone and she blocked me
so anyway so so the right so everyone
knows that it's gonna happen the police
are basically
only deployed around certain areas
they've
they've made lines but if you happen if
you're at the
mendauman mall which is in north
baltimore that place was
smashed apart and i'll say this too
because people will get on me and say oh
well that was
you know this whatever it was every
every race every ethnicity every group
under the sun you saw asians hispanic
white blac everybody
was getting in on this right you were
going to the target you were grabbing a
tv
you were grabbing anything you could get
wither pickup trucks full of appliances
that people and i would just see them
just driving by
with it or a guy like holding a couple
of laptop boxes walking down the street
um i mean it was just chaos just mass
chaos
it and it was in a in an eye blink
everything
that you think our society
is right all of those basic you know
unspoken
you know the unspoken rules but then
also just the actual laws on the books
disappeared and everybody knew it and
everybody it was like a purge night it
was the only difference between i think
the first purge movie had been out at
that point
you know the only difference was that in
the purge they actually have an
announcement
this is just sort of a tacit
understanding that hey you you you know
so
do crimes now here's what happens if
china takes taiwan and the u.s can't
stop it
that's when the rest of the world sees
the united states cannot police anything
they can't defend their allies
and then you'll start think seeing
things pop up in certain areas the u.s
will try to quell certain uprisings
allies will call for help the u.s won't
be able to and then
the taiwan thing in hong kong thing
makes me kind of think of cuba like i
don't think
the u.s should be involved with taiwan
and hong kong purely because it's china
geographically right next to china
whereas i don't think they should mess
with cuba whereas
not that it's it's american soil and not
the taiwan is chinese soil
and if the americans were to invade cuba
and and take it they would do it
economically
anyway yeah fascinating that china has
to its southeast this island that they
claim is theirs
and the people there are not communists
and the us is saying don't you dare
intervene or we'll stop you and then you
have in the southeast of the us
cuba which is communist and you get
china russia and iran saying don't you
dare intervene
which and by the way it's interesting
enough that one thing that people leave
out about the taiwan situation the
reason they don't call themselves the
country of taiwan officially
is because they still maintain that they
are the sovereign power
over all of china and mongolia oh of
course of course
so that's republican what what what we
call mainland china is actually west
taiwan that's right right exactly so
they the government the
republic of china fled to taiwan this is
like in the 60s right so they've never
officially recognized the communist
government of china as the official
government
the u.s did under jimmy carter uh this
was not something that
that kissinger said they were never
gonna do that nixon said never do this
but carter
gave official recognition this is what
switched the seat by the way
so the republic of ty this is actually
uh it's it's not just an academic thing
because prior to the 1970s the seat on
the u.n security council
for china was actually controlled by
taiwan
because that was seen as the
internationally recognized government of
china when that switch happened again
1979
right when that switch happened that is
when you really
now see and then 10 years later was what
tiananmen square and what was
what repercussion did china face what
repercussions did the ccp face
for the tiananmen square massachusetts i
think anything i mean did they anything
any anything sanctions
rewarded they were rewarded with
increased foreign domestic
uh investment they were said a direct
investment they said they were told
we're gonna we just need to bring them
more into the order we they just need
more kfc's and more mcdonald's and
saks fifth avenue and gucci and
louisiana and everything else
if you can just get them more of the
international order well
they'll just be better this is by design
this is it has nothing to do
with human rights it has nothing to do
with human agency it has nothing
to do with all of these things natural
law all of these things we talk it's
money
it's money and power at the end of the
day all these fancy
you know terms and euphemisms that we
can come up with it's just money and
power at the end of the day
they have it and they don't want you to
have it and the idea is that uh
you the pleb will be in the uh renter
class and they will own
is it they don't want you the the pleb
to have it because they're afraid the
pleb will
unseat them like are they afraid of
their are they afraid for their
livelihoods and their family and their
money okay you need to understand yes
that as the
ignorant rabble you truly don't
understand worldly affairs
okay and uh the elite i don't understand
need to manage all of this stuff
otherwise
humans simply become massively
overweight
and addicted to drugs and video games
and they overpopulate and eventually the
earth just falls apart
it is incumbent upon better men to
decide what
you should do with your life is referred
to as no bless oblige
don't worry you will own nothing but you
will be
happy my question though is will i learn
discipline
it won't matter i see why because you
won't
be able to disrupt anything but do these
people have discipline i'm i don't
of course they don't whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa you can't impose
discipline on our betters how dare you
they are the highborn and we are the
local the highborn and that's where
there's no i go back look
people there's there's some guy who's
getting on me for running a game of
thrones blog and that's like how i first
you know kind of was operating on the
internet
and so i was getting on me over this and
they were like oh you're just
game of thrones buyer i was like well i
mean i was an intelligence officer at
the same time
it's not publicly um and i'm like but
that being said
i i think it's actually quite useful to
understanding
where we're going and how we see things
right there is an aristocracy
they are the highborn they're different
factions right like the different houses
um so certainly there are different
factions vying for power
but you would never see a member of one
of the houses of westeros allowing one
of the
one of the they even call them the small
folk there's a word for this in chinese
it means the old hundred names um and
and so there's the idea that they are
the rabble they are the deplorables if
you will
um and we are the elites we are those in
power
yeah why should why why should they
leave the world
the fate of the world in the hands of
people who eat
who you know who drink i mean like a
quart of soda with their
triple cheeseburgers mountain dew
you know yeah i actually tell you sorry
when i was in shanghai so
i was i was at the shanghai american
chamber of commerce and
there is a museum in they call it a
museum of science museum they call it
the shanghai municipal planning
uh museum but it's actually more of a
planning center and
when so codell's congressional
delegations or business delegations or
governors or senators whatever would
come to shanghai
they would always bring them to the
municipal planning center right and they
would say into this museum
and the ccp members this is the local
shanghai
party and actually when i was there the
guy who was the chairman of the city
party of shanghai was a guy by the name
of xi jinping right
he's he's gone on to become a little bit
more prominent congratulations i know
yeah good for him
old buddies we always knew at the time i
actually had the opportunity to meet him
once
um and we always knew that he was going
up to politburo but we didn't realize it
was going to be
that big that fast um i always kind of
referred to him as he was like the
you know the shanghai tony soprano which
is how he carried himself it was huge
entourage you know
overcoat you know the shoulder kind of
deal but
when they would bring our leaders there
right martin o'malley i remember he he
came over when he was governor
they would take they would go down and
they would say wait a minute so you guys
if you decide you want a financial
sector you just here's your set your you
can just
draw on the map and say this is going to
be our financial district and boom
you just have it within 10 years and
it's just there and if you want capital
it's just handed to you
and if you want a high speed rail boom
you just get your high speed rail and
you can
put it wherever you want you say you
want an entertainment center disney
wants a park right now shanghai disney
has a park
um so i was actually there for i was in
some of those early planning meetings
with disney
in shanghai as their meeting with the
ccp to say oh hey we're going to build
our park we want it here
and you know and then you know in the
back of my head i'm thinking
what about all the people who have lived
there those families these are these are
actually uh there's a historic type
of building that they would have in old
shanghai called the kuman
and it's they're these really cool like
interlocking
um houses and sort of like housing units
where you'd have a courtyard and then
around it uh people would go and then so
people could meet the kids would go in
the courtyard
and like older couples would kind of
hang out there took out sort of like
watch over the kids
teach them things and then if they were
these communities everybody was all
stoned
right and i was like what's happening
with all them what about all those that
are there
wiped out destroyed demolished the
people the people they give them money
or anything
no just about you you don't even in
china you you can't
funny enough in china you can't own
anything right you can't you cannot own
land
right you can lease it for about 99
years but the government always owns
all the land meaning this is taking it
actually
it is theirs it's already there actually
the word communism
in mandarin gong-chan literally means
public propertyism right if you if you
translate it directly guangchan
uh it means public property so there is
so private ownership is the opposite of
community
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you